just as we have a notation for music we
have a notation for language we have a
notation for dance we came up with the
notation for juggling and the really
cool thing was that there was some
unexpected mathematics underneath that
then let us predict the existence of
juggling tricks that as far as we knew
had never been done before well the one
I'm going to talk about is called
siteswap if you go on the Wikipedia page
it does have a couple of alternative
names but really the place to start is
with a little bit of juggling so that
you can see what it is we're trying to
capture I'll just do three to start with
and a lot of people think that they'll
go in a circle but in fact the easiest
thing to do is to throw them so that
they all come down in the same order and
if you do that they've got yellow green
orange and then it will be the yellow
ones turn again but if my hands taken in
turns that means the yellow has to
change hands so let me show you yellow
with this hand green with that hand
orange with this and so yellow green
orange yellow green orange yellow green
orange yellow green orange and you'll
see that they have to change hands
because the balls are taking it in turns
and so are my hands and so it just works
out that that's the way it goes so the
first thing to be able to do is at least
to be able to describe that juggling
pattern in any notation that you use and
then think to yourself what can I then
also describe other ones so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to have my left
hand here and my right hand here and I'm
gonna have time running in this
direction so imagine that I'm walking
forwards as I juggle and this more or
less is where my left hand isn't this
more or less is where my right hand is
and then I'll leave out some of the
detail of my hands moving from side to
side but I'm gonna say as I'm walking
forwards I'm going to throw with the
right hand from here and that balls
going to go over to the other hand I
don't know when that balls going to come
down but it's going to go over to the
other hand and a moment later I'm going
to throw with the left hand and then a
moment later I'm going to throw at the
right hand and then I'm going to throw
with the left hand then I'm going to
throw with the right hand and then with
the left hand and I've got this this
rhythm about the whole thing this this
constant metronomic beat going on here
so I'm going to put the the colors onto
here now so this one was with the yellow
ball
this will also show you that they have
to change hands because if I throw the
yellow one here and then I'll throw the
green one next and then I'll throw the
orange one next and then I've got to
throw the yellow one here so it has to
be in the other hand and in truth it
comes down a little bit before that so
if we look at when it comes down it
might come down there and then it's in
my hand for that moment there so there's
the yellow ball going across to that
hand there and then the green ball does
the same thing it goes over here in that
direction and then it's in my hand for a
while there so that will be the green
ball there and then the orange one gets
thrown it goes across to the other hand
and so that's over here in this hand and
then that's the orange ball being thrown
and then the yellow one again and then
the green one again and then the orange
one again and in fact what we are not
with here is a plat and if you juggle
and walk forwards or more particularly
juggle and walk backwards look at the
path that the balls leave in the air
they literally form a braid it's
ephemeral because the balls don't leave
actually leave the trails behind but if
you could imagine that and a guy called
Henry sagermann has made 3d printed
models of juggling tricks that are then
pushed through time pushed through space
so you can see the intermingling
interleaving of the balls but here
what's happening now is you can see that
with three ball juggling what's
happening is I throw the yellow ball
green ball orange balls then I throw the
yellow and again so the length of time
from that throw of the yellow ball to
that throw of the yellow ball is three
feats of the clock three ticks of the
underlying metronome so if you've got
this tic and it goes yellow green orange
yellow green orange then the yellow ball
will be thrown every third time so it's
every third beat that the yellow ball
gets thrown another little comment about
this is that the actual flight time the
time that the ball spends in the air it
has to be less to allow for some time in
the hand what we call the whole of the
juggling ball and that's the dwell the
the time that it's in the hand
we have the flight time here and you'll
see that flight time is a little bit
less than this time that it takes the
balls to cycle around and this is what
we call the cycle time these names are
not universally agreed some people call
it the beat time some people call it the
underlying native time
[Music]
and that's for three vaults now let's
move on to four balls and see what
happens
yellow pink green and white so yellow
pink green white yellow pink green white
so here we go we go yellow pink green
white yellow pink green white yellow
pink green white yellow pink green white
yellow pink green white yellow pink
green want yellow pink green white and
now you'll see that the balls are
actually staying in the same hands
[Music]
so let's actually draw the diagram for
four balls I've got left hand and right
hand throw it here throw it here throw
it here throw it here throw here and
I've got yellow pink green white and
look the yellow
it's the yellows turn and it's the
right-hand turn again so the yellow has
to come back to the same hand and that's
what we saw when I was actually doing
the juggling yellow pink green white so
the yellow ball is thrown here and next
it has to be thrown there so it stays in
the same hand I'm gonna have it Bob
around so it comes around to cut again
it has to come down that a little bit
early I catch it before I throw it
obviously it has to spend some time in
the hand for simplicity we often assume
that that catch is exactly halfway
between in practice it's not in practice
your hand is full for more than half the
time because the only time you can
control the juggling prop is while
you're holding it so you tend to hold it
for as long as you can to give you the
maximum control but you can see here the
yellow ball comes and it's in that and
then the green ball does the same thing
it Bob's
over the time that I'm holding the
yellow ball and then it's in the hand
therefore the green then the yellow ball
gets launched again and this is actually
how it feels it feels like you get these
two balls bouncing over each other in
the hand and if I actually do yellow and
green in the same hand here you can see
that they really do feel like they're
bouncing one over the top of the other
it's almost like they're playing
leapfrog and in fact if you turn this
side on you can see that they're playing
leapfrog over each other although it's
leapfrog through time not leapfrog
through space
but now the interesting thing is if we
have a look at the time that the yellow
ball gets thrown here and then the time
the yellow ball next gets thrown is
there and look how long is that well
I've got a beat here and then I go one
two three four beats and you can see
that that really is four beats of time
from a throw of the yellow ball to the
next strong yellow ball and they're all
doing the same thing so they will all
have a four beat cycle in a moment I'm
going to talk about throwing the balls
to different heights at the moment
they're all doing the same thing so at
the moment I can say that the pattern
has four beats between throws but
shortly I'll talk about an individual
throat being four beats okay so having
seen three balls and three beats four
balls and four beats we can fairly
obviously go on and do five and six and
seven and there's no real interest in
that we can go down and ask what does it
actually mean now based on this kind of
diagram can I draw a diagram for two
balls and what does then in that then
imply for the physical juggling and one
ball and perhaps even zero balls
I'm not going to do that yet because I
really want to get to the payoff I want
to get to the actual notation and why
it's interesting and what happens so I'm
going to go back and I'm going to look
at four ball juggling again yellow pink
green and white so that's what's going
on there and the yellow ball will be
thrown next over here and the pink ball
will be thrown next over here and the
green ball thrown next over here the
white ball thrown next over here we know
that that's what's going on but now
let's cheat now let's do something
slightly different I'm looking at the
yellow ball landing here and I'm looking
at the pink ball landing here and I'm
going well they're good friends why
don't I change places so in fact what we
can have is the yellow ball not come to
here but actually go to there where the
pink ball would go so the yellow ball
actually go
to wear the pink ball would go and the
pink ball actually goes to wear the
yellow ball would go so they exchanged
landing sites they swap their sites it
is a site swap which is where we get the
name of the notation from they are
swapping the places that they go to and
that's great on the diagram what does it
mean physically well if we look at this
the yellow would normally have this
cycle time of 4 but now the time it's
next thrown is 1 2 3 4 5 beats of time
in the future and the pink ball would be
normally 1 2 3 4 bitten it infects 1 2 3
it's 3 beats of time in the future so
what's happening is I'm doing lots of
cycle time for throws so I'm doing 4 4 4
4 4 and then suddenly and without
provocation I'm doing a 5 and a 3
according to my diagram and what's
really nice is that actually turns out
to be exactly the kind of throw that you
do when juggling five balls followed by
exactly the kind of throw you do in
juggling three balls so what's predicted
from the diagram turns out to be the
case in reality and if I demonstrate
that I need the yellow pink green and
white in that order so yellow pink green
and I'm going to do the yellow and the
pink as the high and low as the five and
three so if I just juggled for for a
while and then I'm going to do the
yellow ball high and the people of those
so we can counting down so you three and
you'll see that they have chained cans
as is predicted by the diagram the
yellow did go high
the pink did go low and they landed
perfectly in rhythm and I could just
carry on
[Applause]
so the brilliant thing there is that the
diagram lets us predict that this should
work and in fact this is a juggling
trick that's been known and so now we
can say okay well it's possible to do a
four and it's possible to do a five
three we could have a look at pushing
two of them one later and the other one
has to be brought back more so instead
of having a four four four
it becomes five five and then the four
has to become a two so we end up with
five five two and that can also be done
and now you can see a pattern building
so we get look at these last numbers
here four three two and you predict that
there's going to be a one here all of
these are five so we get five five five
and we predict that this should be
possible and we can do it just from the
numbers we can do it by drawing the
diagram and when we first did this this
was a juggling trick that we didn't know
and as far as I know have actually never
been done when I took this to juggling
conventions people did not know it
after four months people from America
were trying to show it to me
because it was a juggling trick that had
just gone right around the world from
juggling Club to juggling Club to
juggling Club it's called the fake five
because it feels and sounds a lot like
juggling five balls and if I actually do
it here we go so we get yellow yellow
pink green white so we do a single shot
at this starting with the yellow ball
counting three two one five five five
one and those three high throws are
exactly the kind of throw that you would
do if you're juggling five balls but
hang on what's this one what am I doing
with the one and you may have noticed I
did a zip across underneath and we can
actually show that on the diagram why
that becomes inevitable
what's this one business well once again
if we very very quickly sketch this I
say I'm throwing here throwing here
throwing here throwing you're throwing
here trying here I throw this ball I've
only got one I have to throw it from
here it's got to be the same ball so
that means that the ball basically has
to zip across to be held in a hand for a
short time to be zipped across to be
held in the hand for a short time so in
essence if the if the catch is happening
in the middle of those two throws then
basically the ball gets slipped across
spending no time in the air at all and
we can start to talk about the flight
time of the ball and how that compares
and if the catcher's are always in the
middle then we always have the ball in
the hand for one beat so you've got your
cycle time you take up one beat of that
with the dwell time and the flight time
is always there for one less than the
total cycle time that has interesting
implications if you look at zero ball
juggling because that would mean that
the ball actually has to go backwards in
time but there aren't any balls but
there are some interesting things that
you can say about that but here we can
do a 1 a 0 is basically having an empty
hand and so now we can start to say well
what what are all of the possibilities
we can start to draw the diagrams are
there other ways of inventing juggling
tricks are there other ways of knowing
that we've got them all how does this
help us find every possible juggling
trick when jugglers talk about the
height of a ball there are two possible
things that they could mean one is the
physical height but we also talk about
the natural height of a five ball pan
and we'll call that a height five the
natural height of a six ball pattern and
we'll call that a six that varies
according to the speed but when you talk
about the height of a ball then you'll
tend to mean the the number of balls
that you're juggling for that given
physical height
so that the term is often used
interchangeably which can be confusing
but once you use it often enough it
stops being something that you're
worried about there are way diagrams
that help us which are finite state
diagrams but I can show you a finite
state diagram for every possible three
ball juggling pattern where the height
of throat never exceeds five so let's do
that what I do know is that there are
ten places to be and as I draw this
you'll think hang on that's only eight
but I'm going to put an extra one here
in an extra one here and I'm going to
start in a strange place I'm going to
start here and I'm going to label that
arrow as a three and the way you read
this diagram is that you follow the
arrow and write down the number and that
tells you the cycle time of the throw
you're doing so this tells you that I
can do three three three three three
three and that's good because that's the
native three ball pattern from there I
could also do a four and come back with
a two now I haven't talked about a two
but basically if you've got two juggling
balls then really the only thing that
you're gonna do is two two two two two
two two two two two and if you draw the
diagram that really is how it looks
you're just hanging on to the balls you
don't really even need to let them go so
that's green and orange okay so having
done that if I do a four it turns out
that I can actually do a five after that
if I choose to going there there's also
a one coming back here and if I stop for
a moment and pull out some of the
patterns that we've got here four four
one was one of the very very earliest
patterns that we ever found by using
these techniques and that's the one that
I use to torture they're really good
jugglers at the European juggling
convention because it's only three ball
juggling it looks a lot like a pattern
that they know which is called the box
but it's not it's much easier it's much
lower it's much cleaner and every time I
showed it to them and they tried to do
it they couldn't do it so this was a
great way of getting
really good jugglers hooked on this I
where did you find this pattern and so I
could then start to talk about this what
does a 4 4 4 4 1 okay so four four one
what I have to do is I have to do a 4
and then a 4 and then a 1 now I'll do
that I'll start with three ball juggling
and then I'll start I'll just do a
single shot starting with the orange
ball and so next time round so we get 4
4 1 and I'll do it again one shot 4 4 1
and now if I do it constantly we get 4 4
1 4 4 or 4 months and if you watch each
ball goes everywhere and that's the
really cool thing about this pattern is
all three balls are doing the same thing
but out of phase in such a way that they
all meet together and then in the middle
of doing all of that you can simply drop
back to doing 3 balls and it just
disappears it's just a really cool neat
clean pattern and and I love it
particularly cuz it's one of one of the
ones we found
[Music]
now there's an interesting thing that
happens here is that you get patterns
that start and finish here but don't
travel over there and patterns that
start and finish here but don't travel
over there and so within the juggling
world there's a thing known as excited
patterns that you can't do just starting
from the 3-ball cascade and they're a
ground state which are patterns that you
can so for example five three one five
three one you can just patch that into
the middle of a cascade but five one
five one which is the three-ball shower
where the balls go in that cyclic
pattern that everybody thinks they know
is the way you juggle you can't actually
do that instantly starting from the
Cascade starting from the three-ball
figure of eight you have to do a
preparatory throw and there are
different preparatory throws that you
can do so for example you can do a four
five one five one five one point one
what people used to do is a five two
five one five one five one and they have
each has their own merits and so forth
but now every traversal of this of this
diagram every way of wandering around on
this diagram and writing down the black
numbers as you go gives you a juggle a
ball sequence of numbers how many
different sequences are possible how
many different it becomes really messy
if you try and do it by saying how many
are there of a certain maximum cycle
time what we would normally call height
but there is a lovely formula that's are
slightly unexpected and slightly unusual
in its terms but if we ask for a
repeating pattern and ask for a
repeating period of say length N and now
this is the unusual bit that people
don't expect and then we say up to be
balls but not including so that's
strictly less than B balls then the
number of patterns the number of
possible patterns
is B ^ n which is just unexpectedly
simple on my diagram it means at this
point I'm scheduled to do a throw but
all the balls are currently in the air
so I have zero juggling balls to throw
and what's the one a one is this one
that transfers directly from one hand to
the other so if I've only got one
juggling ball I actually just transfer
it from one hand now again my hands are
full for exactly half the time so a 2 is
doing this which is surprisingly
difficult because you have to throw in
catch but in truth in the middle of
juggling and having lots of balls in the
air all at the same time you would never
let that go you actually just hold it up
and show it to display rather than
releasing it you'd never do that and
three the three is actually when we're
juggling three balls it's it's the first
what people think of as proper juggling
but when you look at the the the
notation that we've got the structure
that diagrams the mathematics underneath
it of how the patterns and timings work
this fits neatly and cleanly into the
whole thing as does this for one ball as
does this for zero balls per what
proportion of professional jugglers are
into the math and the notation and what
percentage of them think this is just a
nerdy way of looking at their art it's
fairly clear that almost everybody who's
heard of the notation and it really is
split fairly evenly you know it might
not be 5050 it might be 6040 but but
there's a good proportion of people who
actually can use this to communicate
with each other a slightly smaller
proportion who can use this to devise
notations and of course we've got rules
underneath this and the idea then is how
do we break these rules to do things
which are more artistic potentially then
you get the jazz musicians for whom
writing down music kind of kills it and
they don't want the music written down
they want to ornate around a theme and
as you get out into that side of the the
juggling worlds they don't like this
they know it's there they don't want to
use it if somebody comes to them and
says this is a really cool pattern what
can you make of this they want you to
demonstrate what it is so they can then
elaborate on top of it do variations on
top of it
mutated into something that's that's not
as technical as this can you watch life
juggling and almost see the night yeah
absolutely and again live juggling you
get the the superb fluid dynamic
creative dance performance but then you
look at it and go okay that was four for
one done in a gorgeous way and that was
just for two done in a very clever ways
so I do pick out what the patterns are
and it's really interesting because it
does then mean that I don't have to
concentrate on some of the aspects of it
it frees up my brain to to think about
the rest of it it's like chunking in
math once you get a particular skill
really under control it frees up your
brain to think about the next phase it's
like playing a sport you dribbling the
ball in football playing a forehand
drive in tennis it has to be totally
mechanical has to be totally as easy as
breathing so that it frees up your mind
to think about the structure of the game
the structure of what's going on and so
it is when I watch juggling I see the
pattern and I have the siteswap in my
head of what they're doing and that then
lets me see more about what's going on
in more of the detail underneath
riffle them together is the way we say
it they sometimes do it on the table
this way you know with casino dealer
will do will do that
that's riffle this is called overhand
and the other one I call shushing